the national education association the
nation's largest teachers union is
urging some big tech companies to stop
dangerous disinformation and
misinformation on their platforms
especially when it comes to the pandemic
the union tells the wall street journal
that false information online is putting
teachers and students at risk the
request comes as there are now more than
62 thousand covet hospitalizations in
the u.s that is down 14 percent from
this time last week and the number of
new infections is down 12 from last week
tom hansen has the very latest tom good
morning hey there dana good morning to
you the nation is also seeing an
increase of the number of people getting
shots now averaging about 1 million a
day that's driven in part by booster
shots for people over 65 or those with
pre-existing conditions
children as young as 5 years old could
get vaccinated soon too pfizer has
modified its vaccine and its request to
administer shots to children will be
considered by the food and drug
administration in 15 days if approved
most of the nation's school children
would be eligible to join the biden
administration in its full-on push
against the pandemic more than 186
million americans are now fully
vaccinated and coveted cases are down 40
percent in the past month the president
has asked the department of labor to
prepare an emergency vaccine mandate for
companies with 100 or more employees but
attorneys general in 24 republican-led
states have threatened to sue the
administration for the proposed
requirement writing to the president
your vaccine mandate represents not only
a threat to individual liberty that will
displace vulnerable workers the
attorneys general proposed that the
unvaccinated work remotely the
divisiveness that we saw
with politics i'm seeing that same kind
of trend in health care and that alarms
me but in idaho where dr carolyn
mcfarland is on the front lines the
state has the third lowest vaccination
rate in the nation just 42 percent nurse
alicia luciani also on the front lines
has had enough yesterday was her last
day in the covid ward i've put more
people in body bags over the last two
years than i have in the last nine
it's hard
and in des moines 6 683 flags are now
flying outside the state house to
commemorate the number of iowans lost to
coven i think we just needed a
tangible way
for people to see those lives right
because when you mention a number it's
so abstract volunteers from science for
safe schools say they want to send a
message to governor kim reynolds to
mandate masks for students it's amazing
to me that there's big disconnect
and misinformation that has happened to
the point where we cannot protect our
communities
and guys while so many places are still
debating masks pfizer's vaccine for
children if approved at the end of this
month could be given as early as
november and it should also be noted
pfizer is developing a coveted vaccine
for babies and toddlers under the age of
five years old though that would not be
available until next year michelle all
right tom thanks so much